c'est diane
c'était bien ta journée super journée
sadek et merci beaucoup d'invendus les
filles à eybens dépend tout sérieux ya
un type qui veut lui l'afrique tout le
stock ainsi
confisqué son parité étant soir là cette
fois faut qu'il trouve un vrai boulot et
tutti qu'elle s'excusait du matin ou du
soir
puis tout du midi
votre père m'a dit que vous ne deviez
pas partir sans cadeau parfait je veux
ça
[Musique]
non ça on peut pas vous le donner non
mon père va être déçu moi je contrôle je
parle de tout
qu'est-ce que sur marne nord-ouest
qu'est ce que ça veut dire ça mais tu as
fait buyten je m'appelle pas onstar
notre rémunération serait à la hauteur
du désagrément c'est pas une question
d'argent au revoir
2011 un jour j'ai trouvé le travail de
bouffe j'ai une voiture et un chauffeur
ah oui tu ouvrais la porte hier je te
plaît ce héros ibos pour moi ça va tu
ouvrais la porte hier je te plaît
l'hectare a duré mais travaille pas pour
moi
cette vue à perdre de vue le projet l'a
vu sur des styles qui sèche tu imagines
la chose que ta bijoux
on peut voir au silence
savais une chose c'est aimer ton
[Musique]
depuis un an j'ai plus envie de rien je
garde pour la nuit
et des gants une chute qui l'a
mais sérieux c'est quoi c'est vrai que
j'étais petit j'avais un super président
l'at-elle superbe et a pas de poser
dans la vie quand on aime bien les gens
pour l'expriment vous approchez de la
personne vers la famille troqué perd des
plumes
[Musique]